vous avez construit un empire à partir de zéro
, il s'est métastasé au cours des six derniers
mois, les
gens vont kyster que vos bâtiments
vous rendent immortel quel est votre point le
sentez-vous plus
nous offrons aux plus grands esprits de l'humanité plus de
temps pour réaliser leur potentiel c'est
vivant vaisseau vide si  nous faisons cela il n'y a
pas de retour en arrière
qu'est-ce que c'est quelque chose pour arrêter votre
cœur je suis né le 20 septembre 1980
il s'appelle Edward Kitner pourquoi ne
vous détendez-vous pas et amusez-vous après tout
à votre âge je
savourerais c'était un  élucidation cela a des
effets secondaires bien marquez comment est-ce
possible mec cette femme pense que
la mort de son mari
je vous ai donné ce que vous voulez l'
un de nous sans moi votre esprit sera
moins ce qui vous a aidé
plus dangereux que nous ne le pensions jamais
vous les connaissez chaque avancée médicale